espera un placer darvis la bienvenida a
bruselas la capital del grappa bem-vindo
Bienvenue welcome bienvenidos 16 years
ago all 33 Latin American and Caribbean
countries and the European Union of 15
member states met in Rio de Janeiro for
the first time launching what has become
a truly strategic partnership the
European Union is the main cooperator
largest direct investor and second trade
partner of Latin America and the
Caribbean our challenge now is to become
a partnership for the next generation a
partnership that is symmetrical balanced
and equitable this should be our
ambition for the summit and our future
work climate change is a common threat
we need to achieve an ambitious
agreement for cop21 in Paris salak is
more than just a group of countries it
embodies an ambitious vision of Latin
American and Caribbean unity this summit
is an ideal opportunity to reflect on
what we have achieved and how our ties
must develop in the future but history
has shown us that we need visible hands
collective action the explicit will of
society to attain these things we need
both sides of the Atlantic working
together to create a better world thank
you very much